already one of the best safeties in the
entire national football league after
only two seasons top 10 pick of the new
york jets in 2017 joins us now jamal
adams jamal it is great to see you buddy
how are you i'm great man i had a cup of
coffee i'm ready to go what do you think
of this experience it's awesome man
everything's set up right the right way
um hopefully one day i can you know be a
part of it that's you don't want to be
here i don't want to be here you don't
want to be in this building you want to
be at a hotel i want to be at a hotel
right now um sitting back you know
enjoying you know the the teammates and
enjoying the coaching staff but also you
know enjoying some film and getting
ready for the big game how much do you
hope that the patriots win and tom brady
retires
honestly i don't think he's going to
retire i don't know when he's going to
retire um that's a great ques question
but he might he might play to you know
till he's 60 man honestly the way he's
going is he the one you envisioned when
you took out the mascot last week was
that him
it wasn't it wasn't him that uh i i was
you know uh looking at or you know
envisioning uh but at the same time and
it was all you know for for for the fans
for the kids and um they needed
something we needed some energy you know
what i mean it was it was it was at the
skills challenge and you know everybody
was kind of dying down they were we were
out there for like three and a half
hours and um you know he was just
running around and everybody was booing
him and uh you know i said hey let me
let me take this in my hands and uh you
know you know lighten up the crowd a
little bit and they enjoy they enjoyed
it um you know he chased me after you
know i tackled him and he tackled me um
we talked briefly you know why he
tackled me i make sure he was okay and
he said he was fine um but you know it
was all it was all you know love of the
game and just all for the fans and then
amazing how many people hate the
patriots simply because they've been so
good over the years yeah it's it's
honestly crazy um don't you hope to be
hated that much by everyone else because
it means you got a handful of rings i
mean yeah as long as you're winning um
that's that's that's the you know the
most important thing and um you know
they do a phenomenal job they're well
coached and um you don't have a hell of
an organization and
they continue to get to the big big game
and uh they continue to win speaking of
well coach do you have a new coach in
adam gase who i think is going to do a
very good job for the jets if you had a
chance to speak to him yet very briefly
um through text it was like two or three
texts um um you know i'm just looking
forward to meeting him in person um
through his text you know he said you
know i gave him problems the past you
know the past two years so he's excited
to you know finally be you know joining
the jets uh but you know we're all
excited man we need we need we need new
energy um you know we need we need a new
staff that's gonna bring that for us and
um i'm looking forward to it man i tell
you that i told him that you were gonna
be on with me and that i'm going to get
you to say something really outlandish
that he's going to have to deal with for
the next two weeks so we'll keep trying
to get you to say something that'll get
him really upset right right right man
hopefully uh that's that's not the plan
i definitely want i don't want to you
know start it off like that but um he's
a phenomenal coach and um i know we
picked the right guy what's the most
valuable lesson you have learned in your
two years in the nfl
honestly man is you know uh to to
understand that you know everybody's
gonna have an opinion about you no
matter what you do um no matter if you
you have 10 picks or you have zero picks
um at the end of the day there's going
to be a couple guys out there a couple
people should i say um that's going to
have something negative to say about you
it's just the nature of the business and
at the end of the day you just got to
block those things out and continue your
success how do you block it out though
because it's impossible to block out
everything how do you mentally process
it when you see something you don't like
yeah how do you avoid reacting and
engaging you kind of you just got to
take the higher road in a way man it's
definitely tough because at the end of
the day we're all human you know what i
mean and you definitely want to you know
respond back um but it's definitely
tough at you know at those uh situations
but you got to just kind of understand
that they're not you know doing what
you're doing and they don't really not
everybody understands should i say and
um you can't you can't retaliate um the
best thing to do is uh when someone says
something negative about you is just to
keep it quiet and just let them think
that you know the best thing to do
pull up the bank account
well i don't want to use i don't want to
use that on a man
just for yourself yeah yeah yeah for
yourself you definitely you know you
pull it up and you know you're excited
to smile
that's okay he can have an opinion
that's right small price to pay exactly
to be able to look at these numbers
exactly so uh what do the jets need
going forward
just you know honestly you know small
pieces um we definitely need you know a
couple things to to help sam out um we
could we need a couple you know uh guys
on on the defensive side to you know get
us a lot of pressure we need to you know
get after quarterbacks because that's
the nature of the game it's an offensive
game and now they're giving you know 01
personnels um they're emptying you know
the backfield and they're having you
know linebackers cover running backs and
linebackers covered slot receivers
there's so many things you can do
nowadays so you definitely gotta you
know throw throw in different wrinkles
uh to try to you know confuse the
offense when you were at the pro bowl
how much were you recruiting guys to
join the jets how much were guys
recruiting you to eventually come join
them a little bit of both um you know i
was definitely excited to get around
those guys and uh pick some of their
brains um i definitely was around eric
weddle um you know the whole time just
picking his brain because you know i
think he's one of the best um you know
safeties in the league and for you know
for him to be around this long um and
have a successful career um it's nothing
like picking you know a guy a guy's
brain like that and he's a he's a
tremendous uh you know player but
outstanding outstanding person off the
field i remember when jameis winston
went to the pro bowl the first time he
was coming back from the buffet line and
he sees russell wilson drenched in sweat
and it inspired him hey i've really got
to commit myself was there something
like that for you where you saw someone
you admire someone you respect doing
something you're like hey if i want to
be great all the time i have to do this
yeah eric man eric uh you know he was
telling me you know what he does every
day um you know he works out every day
um he was telling me his routine and how
he's he's he's had this long career um
you know and it's crazy that he says
that he doesn't even get massages um he
just you know he works out he does the
little things the right way and um you
know it's worked for him and you know i
might definitely add it to my routine
and you know i definitely gonna i'm
gonna trust his process i think he does
all those workouts so he can eat a
gallon of ice cream after every win
right with like a whole bag of m m's on
top that definitely might be it now that
you brought that up man i'm here with
pepsi uh the snack box he is a seasoned
professional 100 man perfect pitch
segway what do you got with this yeah
man he's sitting right behind us man uh
you know the the the nickname is snack
bz
and behind us is the the brother of
snack beezy and that's snack breezy so
this is basically a walking vending
machine
you can tell it to do anything you want
it can use the restroom for you
it can grab toilet paper for you it can
bring pepsi for you and it can bring
doritos
all by remote control so it's it's it's
a you know unique um you know little
machine little robot and uh you know
this is the newest thing and the hottest
thing coming out when does it become
self-aware and try to kill us
dad i don't know man that's the next
edition that's the next edition when
when that happens man we just all gotta
you know seek for coverage well my buddy
chris sims has put together some
questions that we are letting folks grab
one out and randomly answer for so pull
one in there and let's see what let's
see what your fortune is let's see what
the answer is from jamal adams
did you have a memorable dream recently
and what was it
i did not
i have i honestly i have not had a dream
in a long time but the last dream i had
was
going to disney world
with my family and i remember falling
off the roller coaster so hopefully
that's not good yeah the first part's
good it did not end well that took a
turn jamal took a very dark turn yeah
that's the last one i kind of remember
and uh it you know it definitely scared
me i think they still do for the super
bowl mvp i'm going to disney world right
you get the trip to disney world so
hopefully the first half of it works out
for you at some point yeah we're not
just don't go on space mountain if you
go honestly all right buddy well hey we
wish you all the best thanks for some of
your time we'll check out uh uh beezy
and breezy yup
and well hopefully the next edition
doesn't uh you know pull out a gun and
take us out all right buddy all the best
to you and thanks for some of your time
i appreciate that we'll see you down the
road yes there is jamal adams jet safety
and we'll be back with more from radio
row in atlanta
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports